okay this this is the boss oh my
goodness
dude dude this is like dark souls stuff
man
hey guys this is video with max tech and
i am extremely excited
because for the first time ever we have
both keyboard
and mouse gaming support on the ipad
this is the first game ever to have it
this is pascal's wager
and it's been over six months since
apple
announced this new feature and we
finally have it so i'm gonna be testing
it out with you guys
in real time i haven't tried it out yet
i'm so excited not because of this game
but because of the potential for the
future of gaming like this on the ipad
for example i really want to play fps
shooter games with the keyboard and
mouse because that's how i grew up
playing it
on the pc now this is huge because this
actually gives the chance of ipad gaming
being competitive
with pc gaming and potentially
overtaking it because as we all know
the mobile gaming market is slowly
climbing and growing larger than the pc
gaming market so this is
extremely exciting especially if in the
future
you'll be able to grab an ipad a
keyboard a mouse and actually cross
play with pc gamers this is just insane
so let's dig right into this and we're
going to start off by going into
the bluetooth settings setting up the mx
master mouse
this is definitely not the most optimal
mouse to use but hey this is what we got
let's test it out all right there we are
we're connected as you can see
right here in the os the mouse is
working
let's switch over to pascal's wager i
think we got to go over to settings
controls keyboard and mouse and look at
that
sweet all right this is working that's
awesome all right so here we are in game
and as you can see the keyboard is
working and let's test out the mouse
left click sweet so left click left
click
nice right click should be like the
heavy attack and let's do the middle
mouse look at that
it's blocking oh my goodness this is so
awesome this is so
exciting because i can't wait to play
games like call of duty mobile what's
even more interesting is
i think later on in this video i'm
actually going to try to sideload
this game onto an m1 macbook
and see if it works right out of the box
running this ipad game now what i don't
really like is that
i've turned up the mouse sensitivity all
the way up
camera sensitivity right and it still
seems kind of slow i actually have it
turned up on my
uh on my ios settings as well and it's
just kind of
i wish it was more sensitive oh
snap dude this guy almost killed me
all right guys this is getting me
excited because
i can't wait till league of legends wild
rift comes out
and i'm really hopeful that they add
keyboard and mouse support
right out of the gate this is like the
witcher 3. oh man this mouse sensitivity
thing come on these guys gotta
update this this is so bad look at that
oh what's up dude
oh step boom
oh yeah boy let's see if i can block
oh snap
oh please oh my goodness all right i'm
gonna use my potion right now oh
diablo immortal that is gonna be a
triple a title
that's gonna be fun oh did i just get a
quest find jerry
all right oh this is jerry okay formula
powder of defense
boom
[Music]
is that jerry
statue and find the tear stone find the
tear stone
okay throwing knife all right let's try
this out
boom okay so how do i jump over this man
leap attack oh man all right
he fell off oh
snap let's do it
get out of here bro snap oh no
dude that's so fair man i'm gonna try
this again
get out of here bros
yes oh snap
dodge boom nice okay that was better man
guys i can't believe this is working
so well already i mean i don't like how
it doesn't
pan very fast come on look at this
literally are you kidding me
is that a boss oh man
oh stop dude
oh my goodness i'm so dead
all right guys this is gonna be a
challenge
dude no
can i even kill this dude let's go
you're weak you're weak bro come on
oh all right i almost got him i need
just some more stamina
yes finally the boss is down
okay this this is the boss oh my
goodness dude this is like dark souls
stuff man
oh dude
i almost got him yes yes yes
i got the dude what's up oh
man all right guys looks like we passed
the first
section of the game that was actually
pretty fun and surprisingly
in the first update the first game ever
to get it it's working pretty well
i don't really like this game but i am
so excited to play
call of duty mobile hopefully they add
this play other games league of legends
wild rift once those games get keyboard
and mouse
supports that is just going to be insane
i am so excited to play those games
but here we are this is just
the beginning so stay tuned because we
should start seeing more games
adapt this mouse support now that the
first game has done it
this is extremely exciting and i can see
a future where
we're going to be able to play these
games on macbooks
in fact let me grab my macbook the m1
macbook air so i'm gonna use imazing
to sideload pascal's wager i have it
open right here
all right guys here we are and for some
reason this mouse is having some really
weird
issues i'm not sure what's up with that
it seems to be disconnecting
let's go ahead and hit full screen there
you go this is pretty nice and look guys
it's working keyboard and mouse support
is working it's just a little bit weird
because it's kind of like not locked
perfectly but
we do know that it actually works that's
insane even just on the ipad
playing with keyboard and mouse support
that's just mind-blowing that we finally
have that
who would have thought that's just
awesome so there you guys go
hopefully you enjoyed this demonstration
of the very first game
with keyboard and mouse support that is
just so exciting and
if you got anything out of this video
you should be excited for
more and more games to gain this support
like call of duty mobile pub g
potentially
and games like league of legends wild
rift that's just gonna be
absolutely insane so if you enjoyed this
video go ahead and tap the like button
click the circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos right
over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video